wir haben heute für die Freien
Demokraten ein traurigen Abend wir haben
einen politischen Rückschlag erlitten
unser Ziel war klar wir wollten eine
linke Mehrheit eine linke Koalition in
Hannover verhindern nach allem wonach es
aussieht er wird die Mitte nicht
gestärkt sondern Niedersachsen wird nach
links gehen das war das was wir
verhindern wollten die Grünen können
sich freuen sie fahren fast sechs
Prozent mehr ein 14,5% und damit die
Hoffnung auf Regierungsbeteiligung in
Hannover Rot-Grün in Niedersachsen die
SPD die gewinnt diese Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen ganz klar bleibt stärkste
Kraft und stellt eben auch weiterhin in
Hannover den Ministerpräsidenten Stefan
weil ja Zahlen die wir natürlich
einordnen wollen und müssen bei uns im
Studio ist BTV Kommentator und
Journalist Georg Gaffron schön dass Sie
bei uns sind schönen guten Tag schönen
guten Tag was war denn für sie jetzt das
Überraschendste an dieser landtagsrolle
Niedersachsen also man muss ja
eigentlich mit allem rechnen denn diese
Landtagswahl findet in einem Moment
statt in dem die Bevölkerung in der
Bundesrepublik und damit natürlich auch
in Niedersachsen höchst verunsichert ist
die wirtschaftliche Krise das nicht
genau wissen was passiert dass der
Ansehensverlust der Bundesregierung in
Berlin das sind alles Faktoren die es
nicht sicher erscheinen lassen wie eine
Wahl ausgeht und ich muss Ihnen sagen
für mich ist das entscheidende und das
hört man relativ wenig ist der doch
überraschend oder manche sagen erwartete
sehr gute Abschneiden das sehr gute
Abschneiden der AFD die AFD hat ihre
Stimmen verdoppelt das muss man sich mal
vorstellen früher hätte das
Sondersendungen gegeben und sie werden
nicht erkennen angezündet worden heute
findet das nicht statt wahrscheinlich
weil man ein bisschen erschrocken ist
über diese Sache über diese Erfolg
dieser Partei denn
das Unwohlsein im Lande ist enorm
ausgebreitet noch nie in der Geschichte
der bundesre haben die Menschen so wenig
Vertrauen in die sie regierenden
Politiker gehabt am Umfragen gleich
mehrere 60 Prozent sagen sie trauen der
Regierung nicht das ist alarmierend auch
zu sehen wo dieser afd-wähler herkommen
nämlich aus dem Lager von CDU und SPD
hauptsächlich naja da würde ich ein
bisschen vorstellen die Wechselräder den
größten wechselwählerstrom hat die CDU
zu verzeichnen 50.000 sind von der
Pfanne ist ja März gegangen
und
die also CDU Wähler vormalige sind zur
AFD
30.000 von der FDP sind zur AFD und das
ist viel entscheidender der Bewertung
40.000 Nichtwähler vorherige das heißt
der AFD ist ein Einbruch ins Lager der
passiven die er schon resigniert haben
gelungen das ist ein ab für mich wäre
das in der Demokratie ein absolutes
Alarmzeichen das heißt wir haben eine
Situation in der die Menschen ganz
offensichtlich in den sich sozusagen als
staatstragend präsentierenden Parteien
nicht mehr das sehen was sie erwarten
das ist finde ich ganz beunruhigend und
das alle anderen Parteien sagen wir
ehrlich bis auf die Grünen verloren
haben alle haben verloren alle großen
Parteien und die FDP ist ganz raus was
ich im übrigen bedauere ist also eine
Situation die ich gar nicht den nicht
richtig wiedergespiegelt sehe in den
Medien da irgendwie will man darauf rum
gewissen Brei wie die Katze den heißen
Brei die AFD ist eine Größe jetzt haben
sie schon gesagt die Verlierer von
Berlin SPD und Grüne sind quasi die
Gewinner von Hannover wie ist das jetzt
zu erklären also das hängt zusammen mit
der Arithmetik natürlich mit der Zahl
der Sitze und der Stimmen sich niemand
bettet das aber ein wie ich es versuche
in die Gesamtsituation sie müssen sich
mal vorstellen diese AFD
Sache gar nicht über einzelne
Programmpunkt und alle möglichen Dinge
das ist alles gesagt aber wir haben zum
ersten Mal eine Partei die ganz Manifest
gegen die Westbindung Auftritt aber
ändern will die gegen Europa kämpft und
die die reson Teams ausnutzt und keine
andere Partei hat das Problem der
wachsenden Flüchtlingswelle wie erleben
zurzeit den Zustrom von Asylbewerbern
aus dem Norden Afrikas die Ampel diese
Themen einfach falsch besetzt dass sie
auch die Themen der AFD oder nicht
besetzt sie gar nicht weil sie keine
Lösungen hat weil sie um das Thema herum
diskut und sie als mein zweiter großer
Vorwurf ist an diriierenden in Berlin
dass sie dem Bevölkerung einreden alles
sei mit Geld zu lösen es ist nicht alles
mit Geld zu lösen sie können die Krise
die wir haben einfach nicht ausgleichen
mit dem Gehaltsscheck
Illusion das führt in die Katastrophe
und sie sehen das ist
Arbeitsgemeinschaft Jugend forscht und
gestern kam die Quittung jetzt will die
FDP auch noch über ihre Rolle in der
Ampel nachdenken wie schon dirserei der
hat jetzt auch noch in der Berliner
Runde ganz klar gesagt nee so geht's
nicht weiter in der Koalition das würden
sie jetzt machen an Christian Lindner
Stelle also
man tut der FDP Unrecht sie haben in
einem bisherigen bemühen natürlich alles
getan um Steuererhöhungen zu verhindern
sie haben sich für ihre Ziele mag man
dazu stehen ob ja oder nein das
Tempolimit haben sich verhindert und sie
setzen sich massiv für die Rückkehr zu
kennen Energie ein das sind schon
gewagte Taten in dieser Gruppierung in
der sie sich da befinden also sich ein
harter Showdown am spielertisch mit SPD
und Grünen
aber
es reicht eben nicht aus und was ich
nicht verstehe ist dass die riesigen
verschuldungshöhe wir haben ein
offiziellen Bundeshaushalt von 300 und
430 Milliarden
Post also nicht der Galerie der
Verschuldung von weiteren 360 Milliarden
es fast eine Million schulden wir sind
was das bedeutet das wird überhaupt
nicht problematisierten dass die FDP
diesen Weg mitgeht halte ich für falsch
aber Die FDP hat schon ihre Rolle es tut
mir leid Lindner ist auch ein bisschen
blass ein bisschen so naja sehr
theoretisch und so vornehmen mit so
einem Oberschüler deren einsam wie du
gemacht hat da müssen andere Typen hin
das Wahlergebnis in Niedersachsen wird
er jetzt höchstwahrscheinlich die
Spannung in der Ampelkoalition nur
weiter erhöhen
zerbricht die Ampel oder willst du noch
drei Jahre weiter unterschätzen Sie
nicht das süße Gift der Macht
an jedem einzelnen der da sitzt hängen
Sekretärin Freunde die befriedigt wurden
bis in die Kommunen hinein das ist der
Honigtopf und für den Honigtopf vergisst
man auch schnell mal sein Gewissen und
seine Grundsätze zumindest heutzutage
und das bedeutet dass
die werden noch weiter wurscht Stunden
das ist ganz klar aber eines Tages
fürchte ich kommt der Augenblick der
Wahrheit und ich hoffe nicht so dass wir
in Deutschland soziale Unruhen bekommen
dass die Leute auf die Straße gehen und
zwar die normalen Menschen nicht die
verrückten die sie an die Straßen kleben
wie heute wieder in Berlin dann acht
Stellen und in die Innenstadt Laden
legen eine absurder Zustand sondern die
ganz normalen Leute die in der Regel
früh aufstehen arbeiten gehen dann auf
die Straße hat man in der Ampel mit
dieser Wahl quasi die rote Karte gezeigt
noch nicht ganz also er hat sich ein
warmen Schuss aber sie sehen ja wie es
im Bund ist ich finde für die Union ist
das ein ganz wichtiger Punkt ich habe
mich gewundert Friedrich Merz ist
gestern gar nicht im Fernsehen
entschieden hat er mit seinem
Armschmerzen gehabt ich hatte auch
gerade gebrochen manchmal weh aber
gerade dann so am Abend tut's dann weh
ich verstehe es nicht denn äh das ist
sind die Konservativen in der Union über
die Frauenquote entsetzt sind und von
März enttäuscht sind und einfach jetzt
sagen und dann reden wir eben mal die
anderen darüber sollte man nachdenken es
ist alles in Bewegung ich wäre heute
nicht in der Lage zu sagen was in einem
Jahr ist es ist ein Schuss vor den Burg
auch wenn die alle sagen wunderbar die
SPD sagt
naja es ist irgendwie ein richtiger Sieg
und bei den Grünen die hatten auch ein
bisschen mehr erwartet danke herr Franz
ihre einschätzen
[Musik]